هذه الحادثه التي تابعها كل محب الصقور في
مصر اثرت عليهم بصوره كبيره وربما غير
طريقه تفكيرهم في ملاحقه الصقور ومتابعتها
فمهما يكن ليس للسحراء كبير
هو كان دائما مخيم بتاعه
اي حد ما عندوش مكان لسه ما عملتش مكان
لسه بيدور على مكان
هو مش من الناس اللي معه فلوس ياما يعني
هو زينا كده عادي
كل الخيرات وتلاقي الناس بتبات عنده يعني
دي اهم صفه فيه ودي من اكثر المواقف
الواحد يعني كلنا كان متاثرين به وعارفين
ان هو قد ايه انه كريم انه بياثر على على
صيده هو
[موسيقى]
وتقليل السفاره امنيه يرغبها الكثيرون من
الصقارين في مصر خاصه مع امكانيه زياده
الجذب السياحي على غرار دول الخليج وهو ما
يقوله لنا احمد الشريف الذي نظم سباق
للسقور في الصحراء وادي النطرون اطلق عليه
اسم حورس وجاء اليه محب الصقور من مختلف
الاماكن يعني انا اتمنى طبعا الهوايه
هي ترد على البلد بفائده كبيره جدا لان في
عندنا حاجه اسمها السياحه
البيئيه من مشاهده الطيور بقى ل- اا
لاقامه مزارع هنا الاقصار الثور
المستشفيات لرعايه الثور طبعا انت عندك
منطقه الخليج دي همم نمره واحد في العالم
بالنسبه للاقتناء والتدريب الثور بالذات
فهنا طبعا لو اتعملت مزارع على الاكثار او
مستشفيات زائد الموضوع المسابقات والموضوع
اللي همم
ان ان السايح يجي العربي يجي بالسهر بتاعه
هنا في مصر يدخل مصر
يبقى في مسابقه عالميه هنا بتتعمل زي
السباق بتاعنا حورس ده ان هو يبقى عالمي
سباق عالمي
[موسيقى]
في ظل اهتمامين بالحياه البريه والحفاظ
على التوازن البيئي واستضافي مصر لقمه
المناخ كوب 22 7 يظل الحلم قائما لدى
الكثير من السقاريين بان تصبح مصر وجهه
الهوايه السيجاره
[موسيقى]